If a body is found in a field, and the cops
suspect foul play is involved, establishing
the exact time of death is critical.
Figuring out the deceased’s final moments
can help investigators corroborate people’s
stories to ultimately hone in on the killer.
But how do you do that?
There are a few traditional ways to tell when
someone died.
Forensic examiners can measure body temperature,
skin color, and degree of rigor mortis.
Each of these changes as the body begins decomposing,
so knowing the stage of change they can work
backwards to figure out the time of death.
But all those methods only really work in
the first 72 hours; any longer and those factors
have piqued, meaning the changes have happened
and there’s no more data to glean.
So, when a body has been a corpse for more
than three days, investigators have to use
other methods to determine the time of death…
one way is to look at all the different insects
that feed on dead human flesh.
*gross sound*
Insects are drawn to the gasses and fluids
released from a decomposing body; to them,
it’s fertile ground to lay their eggs and
cultivate their young.
*disgust face* The first insect to reach a
corpse is usually a blowfly, which will lay
eggs within two days of the person’s death.
Flesh flies also move in early in the decaying
process.
Decomposing body fat attracts hide beetles
and pyralid moths.
As time go by and flesh breaks down, other
species of flies and beetles that have mouths
to chew tougher food move in, consuming that
dead flesh.
From there, the corpse becomes an ecosystem
with insects feeding on the corpse also feeding
on each other.
This is all super gross but super important.
Entomologists know the life cycles of these
insects, specifically the all-important blowfly
that lays its eggs in the dead body first.
When determining time of death, they can look
at the stage of development of the blowfly
— whether it’s an egg, larva, pupa, or
adult — and take into account environmental
factors like heat and insect patterns to work
backwards and figure out approximately when
the blowfly laid its eggs, which can tell
them the time of death.
We’re really good at this, but there’s
a problem… we need to know exactly what
species that larva is.
And they all sort of look alike.
The examiner needs to know the species for
a better estimation of development time and
time of death.
They can do a DNA test on an egg, but that
can be pricey.
The cheaper option is to collect the egg and
let it grow to adulthood in a lab to figure
out the species, and work backwards from there.
Of course, if you’re trying to find out
who killed someone and left them in a field…
waiting three or so days for a fly egg to
become a fully-formed insect is stressful.
A criminal can flee to a new country by then!
Knowing the egg-identification thing is an
issue, an organic chemist teamed up with a
forensic entomologist to apply real-time mass
spectrometry to blowfly eggs.
And it could be a game changer to forensic
science.
Before we get to that though, they had to
learn about all these species of flies.
To do that, the researchers put pork liver
in traps hidden around Manhattan.
This is real science.
They attracted four species of blowfly, and
trapped them before they laid their eggs.
They determined their species and then put
them on a fresh liver to seed with their spawn.
That way they knew what species were laying
eggs where.
Then they collected the eggs and tested each
in a mass spectrometer to get a chemical fingerprint.
Mass spectrometry is really complicated to
explain, but basically: a sample is ionized,
the atoms are sorted by mass and charge and
it gives you a graph that looks like this.
With this we can figure out what atoms something
is made of, what they call the chemical fingerprint.
And since everything is made of atoms, we
can apply this technology to things like uncovering
the amino acids in blowfly eggs!
Knowing the species then analyzing the eggs
gave them the first ever chemically-based
way to identify blowfly eggs, and it only
takes minutes to do it!
Ideally, if this tech works, entomologists
can use all the data from the crime scene
and a quick mass spectrometry check of the
fly larvae to find an approximate time of
death.
But, we can’t use this to catch criminals
yet.
Scientists will need to measure the chemical
signature of more species, and then create
a database against which spectra of unknown
eggs can be compared.This promises to advance
forensic entomology, and by extension help
investigators act quickly when faced with
a dead body in a field.
But let’s say no one found the body in the
field until it was picked clean by insects…
then forensic examiners have to figure out
what happened using just a skull!
I talk about that in this episode right here.
Did you make it through this video without
vomiting?
I almost didn’t.
Let us know your thoughts in the comments,
subscribe and come back here for more Seeker